Pedro is supposed to practice piano for
3/4 of an hour every day
today he is practice for 1/4 of an hour
what fraction of an hour does he need to
practice so let's visualize 3/4 so he
needs to practice 3/4 of an hour's so if
this represents an entire hour so this
represents an entire hour so let's
divide it into fourths
so now divided into halves now let's
make it into 4 equal section now it's in
2/4 so he needs to practice so he needs
to practice 3/4 of an hour so he needs
to practice 3/4 of an hour that was my
attempt at drawing an arrow so let me
shade it in so he needs to practice he
needs to practice 3/4 of an hour this
gets us to 3/4 3/4 right over here so he
needs to practice 3 out of the fourth of
an hour so this is 3/4 now it says he is
already practiced for 1/4 of an hour so
he's already practiced for 1/4 1/4 so
how much more does he need to practice
how much more does he need to practice
well he needs to practice this much more
he needs to practice this much more than
you might already see the answer
visually but let's think about how to
represent it as a as a fraction
expression so let me write it like this
so this is how much he needs to go how
much how much does he need to practice
so he needs to do a total of 3/4 he's
already done 1/4
he's already done 1/4 so if you subtract
1/4 from the 3/4 you're going to get
this amount right over here you're going
to have to get you're going to get the
amount that he needs to practice now
this already has the same denominator so
this is going to be equal to 3 minus 1
over 4 3 minus 1 over 4 which is equal
to 2/4 and you see that right over there
he still needs to practice 1 & 2 out of
the fourths 2/4 now 2/4 we know is the
same thing as 1/2 there's a couple of
ways to think about it you could say hey
look this is half of the
length of this entire thing as a little
bit on this end and that end or if you
made if you made four blocks like this
if you make four blocks if you make four
equal blocks and if you were to shade in
two of them you see that you have shaded
in one half of the blocks this is the
exact same amount as if I just divided
into two sections and I shade it in only
one of them to force is equal to one is
the same thing as one half and if you
wanted to work it out mathematically you
just have to do the same thing to the
numerator and the denominator so let's
divide the numerator and the denominator
by two because they are both divisible
by two that's actually their greatest
common factor so two divided by two is
one
four divided by two is two so what
fraction of an hour does he need to
practice he's got to practice half an
hour